hey everyone welcome to biology
professor i have another short video for
you guys today that is a little bit
different from my normal whiteboard
format today i'm going to be talking
about beach blight aphids i discovered
some of these in my garden and thought
that they were cool and a little
horrifying and thought that you might
like to see them too so that's actually
what you see on my virtual background is
the underside of a leaf from my garden
and all of those white things are beach
flight aphids um how did i identify them
not knowing much about aphids
uh myself i used my naturalist app i
snapped some pictures and tagged the
location and the top hit was beach
blight aphids i was able to google those
look at more pictures and confirm that
that does appear to be
um the cause of this infestation
so let me share my screen with you guys
and you will be able to see a little bit
more about these guys
so
uh let me go ahead and hit present here
i've got a few things to show you so
yeah so beach blight aphids uh these are
the scientific name guerrilla
procephalus embrocator uh never heard of
it before i assume i'm pronouncing that
pretty pretty close to the correct way
and all of the images and videos here
are by myself
and so here we've got uh beach blight
aphids here you see the same picture
that is my virtual background each one
of these little white fuzzy things is an
aphid here you see one that um i took a
video of and it was actually like you
know moving along this stem
so i found this infestation
um basically i moved into a new house a
little while ago
and i don't quite know
what kind of plant this is on i believe
it is an azalea but we had a winter
storm
prior to
my purchasing of this house and
most of the plant even in the spring and
summer seemed really dead just very
brown but there was some new growth
coming in from the roots and so i
discovered this infestation when i came
to cut away all of the old dead brown
growth
to make room for the new growth coming
up i do believe based on the leaves that
it is in azalea
but it hasn't flowered so i can't
totally confirm that
i also will say that there were ants
everywhere around this plant all in the
the soil and the mulch around it it was
just teeming
with you know hundreds or thousands of
ants and i had disrupted them and they
were very unhappy with me
ants are known to farm
various other organisms including aphids
because aphids will secrete
this um like sugar rich compound
sometimes it's called honeydew
and so ants will actually farm aphids
they will
farm them and raise them as a food
source and so i believe that's what was
happening with this particular
infestation
i've got this video that i will play for
you guys i took this you know when i
found it you can see some of these
aphids moving along this right here just
shows the plant that i was cutting down
i had already cut away
huge amounts of just brown brown leaves
or sorry brown brown stems
uh and just to clear up room and then i
found that the new growth coming in from
the roots was all infested
i think you can see all of the white
aphids on the underside of all of these
leaves so i had begun cutting them off
as well
and then thought i would catch a video
look right there look at it just moving
walking
these things they were attaching
themselves to my arms to my clothes
um
it really was just you can see
they're on the underside of a bunch of
these leaves there were a whole whole
bunch of them um after i had gotten rid
of them i read
that if you
you know like frighten or intimidate
these aphids they can do something
called the boogie woogie dance which is
where they all kind of like
waggle back and forth in what i guess is
supposed to be intimidating maybe
intimidating to another bug i'm not sure
um i did not witness that um
phenomenon myself
so again there's you know the mostly
kind of dead plant i'd already cut down
most of it i was just trying to clear up
some more room for it
and
whoops going too far
so what did i do i used a watering hose
and i just soaked the plant i sprayed
off all of these aphids with just a
strong
stream of water
and
i had my husband put down ant killer
pesticide and i haven't seen any more
aphids since the ants are another story
unfortunately we keep finding kind of
ant infestations at various points
around our front and backyard and we
just treat them when we find them but
haven't seen any more aphids since then
so that right there is my uh experience
so far with beach blight aphids i will
say you know they weren't on a beach
tree i'm pretty sure what they were on
was an azalea i can't really find
um
much evidence of them being on azaleas
so that's a little surprising
uh i suppose it's possible it could be a
different kind of aphid but my eye
naturalist app said beach blight aphid
and certainly
phenotypic phenotypically
morphologically they look exactly like
that so if anyone else has had
experience with these things i would
love to hear about it um how you
found them how you got rid of them
uh
and just yeah tell me all about it and
thank you guys
for
watching biology professor and i hope to
see you next time bye